herr professor oder welchen sinn macht
es für wladimir putin jetzt dort in die
ukraine zu gehen
nun da die mir tut ihn tut das jetzt was
er seit 2008 angebahnt hat was sich zwei
seit 2008 vorbereitet hat und was man im
westen zu lange nicht in seiner ganzen
tragweite hat wahrnehmen wollen schon
2008 ist punkten militärisch gegen die
ukraine vor gegen georgien ursprünglich
vorgegangen
2014 militärisch in die ukraine
vorgegangen und immer hat putin
letztendlich kein geheimnis daraus
gemacht worum es geht es geht um einen
groß russischen nationalismus putin hat
gesagt der untergang der sowjetunion war
die größte geopolitische katastrophe des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts nicht weil es
putin um den kommunismus gegangen wäre
sondern um die russischen großmacht
ambitionen aus der zeit des zarenreiches
die die sowjetunion dann politisch
fortgesetzt hat und genau dort setzt
putin wieder an und worum es jetzt geht
es um das gegeneinander eines russischen
imperialismus in der tradition des
zarenreichs oder die zelte
selbstbestimmungsrecht der nationen dass
wir für eine grundlage der
regelbasierten multilateralen
außenpolitik handeln das heißt halten
das heißt hier geht es um ganz ganz
grundsätzliches und das muss sich der
westen das muss sich deutschland sehr
nahe also herr oder lassen sie uns noch
einmal die ukraine als ganzes land
betrachten würde wladimir putin
ausreichen nur die ost ukraine
einzunehmen was sehr unwahrscheinlich
ist oder geht es dann noch weiter wie
weit wir gehen
wieweit putin gehen will das wissen will
nicht aber wir wissen wie weit er
gegangen ist es hat begonnen mit der im
2014 dann mit du jetzt und nur hans wir
haben sehr karte gesehen schon über die
jahre hin und jetzt offen militärisch
wladimir putin hat immer gesagt dass die
ukraine eigentlich nur ein staat von
russischen gnaden und russischer
herkunft und eigentlich kein
eigentlicher vollständiger start ist
insofern richten sich die an beziehungen
und ins auf die ukraine ob dann auch die
früher einmal habsburgische westliche
ukraine also galizien mit gemeint sein
würde das weiß man nicht genau aber
wissen sie das ist am ende auch eine
relativ unerhebliche überlegung shooting
bestreitet der ukraine nicht nur das
selbstbestimmungsrecht sondern auch das
lebensrecht als unabhängiger staat und
das ist ein grundsätzlicher angriff auf
alles das was uns in der westlichen welt
aus westlicher sicht auf eine
regelbasierte
multilaterale staaten ordnung lieb und
teuer und heilig sein sollte das heißt
hier geht es um alles und da ist die
frage ob dann lemberg noch mit gemeint
ist nicht mehr die entscheidende wahl
warum geht er ausgerechnet jetzt diesen
letzten großen schritt nun ob woran das
jetzt ganz kurzfristig die ganz
kurzfristig sicherlich aus der an die
rücksichtnahme auf china die olympischen
spiele erst zu ende gehen zu lassen
ansonsten sehen wir doch eine
systematische eskalation der russischen
politik über die letzten 17 jahre hinweg
deshalb 2005 schon rhetorisch angefangen
2008 es hat man im westen gerne
übersehen sie haben die ersten
militärischen interventionen
stattgefunden und das hat sich über die
jahre immer weiter gesteigert ob putin
jetzt noch wieder eine persönliche
panik ab weil russland perspektivisch
und ausdauer an macht verlieren könnte
das ist spekulation entscheidend ist
dass wir die entwicklung über die
letzten jahre hinsehen und das ist die
geschichte einer permanenten eskalation
im sinne eines groß russischen
imperialistischen nationalismus der das
existenzrecht der ukraine in frage
stellen und das selbstbestimmungsrecht
der nation ich sage das noch einmal ist
die grundlage der westlichen
vorstellungen von einer regelbasierten
staatenwelt herr wulff kann putin denn
jetzt noch stoppen gibt es überhaupt
irgendwas in der ukraine wird ihnen
wurde hand nicht stoppen die frage ist
wie der westen sich verhält und immerhin
da gibt es ja klare übereinkunft über
ein sanktionsregime aber der westen muss
natürlich um sich nicht lächerlich zu
machen und um nicht vollständig zu
versagen wo es diese sanktionen
natürlich nun in aller härte anwenden
weil sie verhindert nach der
historischen dimension fragt wir sind ja
immer auf der suche nach historischen
vergleichen wir haben den einen großen
historischen vergleich ist der von
münchen 1938 als die westmächte nicht
nur territoriale interessen erster
sudetenland der tschechoslowakei
preisgegeben haben und kurz darauf die
existenz der gesamten technik nowak ja
immer gesagt dass island eine würdelose
schwäche der westmächte war die dem
diktator einfach einen anderen staat zu
seiner expansion überlassen haben man
hat immer gesagt nie wieder münchen aber
genau an dem punkt sind wir jetzt wo
lassen sie mich gleich noch eines
aufmachen wenn wir sagen es gibt zwei
große vorkriegs geschichten des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts die eine ist
die der juli krise von 1914 und die
besagt dass man möglichst lange
verhandeln sondern und nicht zu früh
kriegerisch tätig werden soll und dann
gibt es die von 1938 39 sagt einem
gewaltbereiten diktator muss man
entgegentreten
die lektion von 1914 hat der westen
insofern beherzigt als man nach der krim
nicht sofort militärisch oder dass man
so reagiert hat dass man dass die
fehlten nicht ganz abreißen lassen jetzt
aber ist nicht mehr 1914 jetzt ist 1938
39 und jetzt muss man diesen
gewaltbereiten diktator der nicht bereit
ist das lebensrecht souveräner staaten
zu respektieren mit aller konsequenz
entgegentreten
während wir sprechen schon mal kurz auf
das erlaubte tempo schröder wir erwarten
ein statement von lars klingbeil in
diesen minuten eigentlich die mikrofone
sind aber noch leer auch bundeskanzler
olaf scholz hat für 12 uhr ein statement
angekündigt sprechen wir kurz weiter in
der zwischenzeit ich bin einigermaßen
schockiert dass wir in dieser situation
2022 tatsächlich die beiden großen
weltkriege zum vergleich nehmen ist die
situation so dramatisch
ja ist sie wissen sie wir haben uns in
deutschland angewöhnt zu sagen gewalt
ist keine lösung ja aber was ist denn
wenn gewalt eine option ist und gewalt
ist eine option für wladimir putin
übrigens möglicherweise auch china eben
verhältnis oder im umgang mit taiwan wir
haben uns in europa auf diese
historische insel der seligen
zurückgezogen und gemeint für sein aus
der weltgeschichte entlassen gewalt ist
keine lösung für die zivil macht
deutschland am schluss heißt das aber
dass wir uns illusionen hingegeben haben
schon das leugnen der realität ist noch
nie ein gutes rezept gewesen und mit der
realität umzugehen auf mir dass es noch
diplomatische lösungen gibt in welcher
form auch immer vielen dank professor